welcome sorry to this video panopticon
oh I've got one hundred percent against
his player I wouldn't even and thought
that I have played him before ok so the
Kings Indian maybe try some line that I
haven't played yet it's a little bit
like the arbor buck but the bishop is
only three let's see night a 6s them the
main move now no it's going 45 yeah do I
play this age for business I can them a
Troy drive a preemptive strike on the
King side as long as I've not castle
this is a good idea like sometimes just
place h5 yes not just blocking the whole
thing and maybe allowing Nigeria type
lay f3 maybe to cover that yeah maybe
okay
seems that he wants to open up the C
file for coming to play but not not
clear how good this is especially
considering that he has played a five
already I always have difficulties with
assessment with assessing this kind of
positions should I go a 40 s Susan this
is a bad idea I'm going to do that to
prevent a for Queen 85 this is quite
often on some counter blame okay okay
well Queen d2 it's human I'd be three
it's not a move but it's close close to
being a move he's not threatening a
check here I can't do that actually yeah
maybe this is not bad just putting this
night on this this week square and
asking him how he is going to continue
like hooks you one be three just keep
keep things under control
yeah I wonder should I should I just
castle yeah maybe just Castle young age
for it does not look ideal but I don't
see what he what you can do to to
exploit it okay yeah possibly is going
to really play a five yeah i was
thinking night I wonder about 93 if this
is a move I think it's an idea not easy
very difficult position you know maybe
cannot take with the Queen now it is
really in this pin so it's not not so
comfortable yeah i was thinking that
this should be quite good no d6 was my
idea and I don't have agents here
opening up for Bishop c4 and 425 also d7
of course as a threat and if he takes it
c5 will fall with Queen d5 our Queen
takes Queen takes Knight takes Bishop c5
that would definitely be good for white
yeah
it is it is somehow good for white not
not not not sure how much I mean how
much advantage this this actually brings
um should be should be six is also yeah
I'm not sure don't want to fall super
far behind him
I really might just take take the
airport I mean the a porn is not not
great cave on yeah this i thought was
was like hardly playable maybe it is but
it looks that looks with jackie better
let me think about it i can also give
the check the check first and Bishop c5
check should be six and Bishop g5 why
it's not really muttering much I think
jack will be successful ship see if I
have check unfortunately okay check
king is coming to have six maybe my
turkey endgame tricky and the power in
itself is not not such a big deal but
the bishops do exert some pressure it's
very delicate though not easy bring the
King up maybe I don't really see a way
way forward is giving me some ideas with
with g4 maybe hmm what checking this
okay I can't do this first keep the
point for the moment
the bishops at least keep them king in
check blacks king is not able to do much
and I have I need my own I need the king
and play I King it too but hard to go
from there okay i basically invites me
to go them on e to possibly he wants to
go nite be five yeah i have to have to
do it anyway what else is there and not
be 5 i'm playing 55 I guess I but ok mmm
yes nighty 6 as a discovered check
sure that isn't that isn't so great
regex not easy not at all trying to win
the pawn I know is in a cell phone
that's a pretty bad pin
check check black for Fitz on time and
no it's it's winning right there is no
no defense no respective picking this up
yeah it was a difficult endgame simply
due to the bishop and the bishop air in
this open position and yeah the computer
gives me a total win here but then so I
did a decent assessment here but I
played I didn't play precisely ah this
is much stronger mmm this is much
stronger yeah and here he I'm really in
fantastic shape let's check and we
should be seven and stuff yeah that's
great really yeah okay so this is this
is ok but we can play Bishop age 6
didn't see that one that that saves
black and that's a real problem yeah
yeah everything's in order again Jack
Jack yeah but it's not a simple
technical task at least it didn't look
like it Jan yeah but it really really
got lost after that before that he could
fight but here he is in a deadly pin
this is this is impossible to get rid of
now and I'm winning now with exactly the
maneuver that happened in the game ok
thanks for watching